nous avons examiné
en commission ce projet de loi de
finance et je le dis aux Français pris
dans les files d'attente interminables
vous feriez mieux de soutenir les grèves
parce que vous êtes les prochains sur la
liste parce qu'à chaque fois que vous
vous saignez le portefeuille à la pompe
vous engraissez des spéculateurs et des
profiteurs de crise à chaque fois que
vous remplissez votre caddie au
supermarché des rapaces vous volent
votre temps de vie et de travail parce
que l'inflation chers collègues c'est du
vol de temps de vie et du vol de temps
de travail chaque pourcentage en plus
d'inflation représente pour les Français
du temps passé à travailler gratuitement
pour remplir les poches d'un capitalisme
toujours plus sauvage et brutal
alors
nous leur disons soutenez les grèves
soutenez les grèves et battez-vous
battez-vous contre la vie chère
battez-vous contre les spéculateurs
battez-vous pour en poser enfin dans ce
pays la taxe sur les super profits et
marcher à nos côtés le 16 octobre pour
exiger le droit à vivre dignement et la
réalité c'est que vous êtes toujours du
côté de ceux qui bloquent vous n'êtes
jamais du côté de ceux qui font avancer
notre pays qui travaillent qui se lève
tôt le matin
c'est ça la réalité et vous le démontrez
encore une fois c'est dur de faire des
propositions crédibles c'est dur de
chiffrer les propositions qu'on fait
c'est dur d'expliquer comment on va
financer les propositions qu'on fait
devant les Français si vous voulez
couper cours au débat si vous voulez
qu'elle soit adoptée de motion de rejet
pour pas qu'on débate sur ce budget
c'est parce que vous ne savez pas
comment expliquer aux Français ce que
vous feriez pour les protéger vous ne
savez pas comment expliquer aux Français
comment vous financieriez vos mesures ça
fait des mois que vous expliquez que
vous vous opposez à tous les textes que
nous prenons pour le quotidien des
Français parce que vous préférez
manifester c'est ça votre solution quand
est-ce qu'une manifestation a rempli le
frigo des français quand est-ce qu'elle
a fait baisser une facture la réalité la
réalité c'est que vous ne voulez pas
débattre parce que c'est difficile de
débattre parce qu'il faut faire des
propositions et les expliquer